you want to look fresh in the apocalypse
or do you want some money to barter
we always want to look fresh jeff
what's up cakes family it's meech here
welcome to our new debate show
sneaker swap where we argue a lot
fellas the topic for today is if you had
the dior jordan one
would you trade it for a half a year's
rent
okay 5 million people try to secure
these sneakers
only 8 000 pairs were made available to
the public worldwide that
is very very very rare what are we doing
here
christian i want to hear from you first
man that's tough
that's tough man i came in front like
half years rent sounds mad good but i'm
going to yours
i'm keeping it to yours like you said 5
million people
try to cop 8 000 pairs you got sitting
on that bro you got to sit on that like
honestly the years will be the most
coveted pair since the red october is in
like in 2014.
only other shooter might be even close
by the off-whites and like i still think
that red octobers are higher than that
and if you just think about it like
people who care about october is like
it was only 250 when i first dropped and
people sold for 4k
now it's looking like a 10k so you mean
to tell me if i got these dior ones
right right and they're going for like
15 right now
six years or so i'm looking at what 30k
or so i'm keeping that
plus the shoot just feels luxury it
feels like everything you want
i don't want to see any other jordan
logos out here dior on top of it now
so like i'm keeping the shoe i
i absolutely love to hear that man like
having these shoes has had like being a
part of very very exclusive club
perfect uh cj talk to me i mean
okay so i love you christian man and i
don't and i
you got into the math which is a perfect
way to break this down
yeah and i don't want to remind us of
this but we are in a pandemic
if i have the dior's i gotta sell them
if i can guarantee some rent
i mean so i'm in la right now right my
rent six months that's like
uh twelve or two thousand a month that's
like you know
that's twelve thousand dollars and also
too i'm a bad sneaker dealer like
i would give these up for like five
thousand and be like man i made it and
it's like no
it's worth way more than five thousand
dollars so i if i was if
if i was a good businessman or a real
estate agent maybe
but i'm just like i know my situation
right now and i would i would sell those
things or i would
get the rent that's where i'm standing
cj five thousand dollars
that's just like unattainable for me so
that's what every sneaker to me that i
can't get my hands on that's they're 5
000 bucks
fine cool so there's a couple of things
about me right like i've never been
the avant-garde fashion guy i don't
think i've ever owned anything from a
major
uh high fashion high price retail brand
so me
owning the diors feels like kind of a
clout chase
it kind of feels like i'm stunting and
if my first
item from dior is a pair of sneakers
it's kind of like
what are we really doing with life right
so that would be the first thing
but they they're fire though let's let's
let's let's be let's be honest this
isn't
their their [ __ ] fire right but
there was a wise philosopher jimmy
mcmillan who once stated
yeah that the rent is too damn hot
all right we live in a major city
i live in new york city where the
average rent
y'all while i'm coming here living first
of all the average rent is three
thousand dollars
three thousand dollars in manhattan
right or even two thousand just like you
said we'll go to la
twelve thousand dollars i can get
these things are going for like eighteen
twenty five you telling me i could get
twelve
thousand dollars for for that one time
i think it's something that i consider
i mean i want to say i hear you
considering it but like
i think christian i love i think you
made a great point about
sitting on it for a year sitting for two
years and seeing that value double over
time jeff like i know that you can get a
nice little
10 12 k lump sum but what if it could be
40k what if it could be 50k
all right well let's talk about it we're
gonna talk about financial freedom today
like let's let's get into it
i could take that twelve thousand
dollars and i can
invest it in a whole lot of ways what if
i buy three or four
other kicks that are kind of priced in
the same way
and sit on those and then flip those in
a year i could probably double up what i
have under you do yours
plus you're also considering the fact
that people actually have the money
to buy these sneakers maybe if you maybe
if you fall upon
a celeb or athlete or somebody who has
that much disposable income
that they're going to pay for that then
god bless you
but other than that i could take that
money i could flip it in the stock
market i can do
i could do a whole lot of other things
it might be even smarter to wait the
next year
and flip it for the 40k that you're
talking about again either way
you're going to get that money is there
going to be a next year though
i hate to harp on that right but then
also
but jeff okay you don't want to look
fresh in the apocalypse
do you want some money to barter i don't
want to look fresh jeff
i don't want to be too cynical here but
i want to bring up what jeff said
earlier too
for most of us this would be our first
dior piece right
so like and i feel like the philosophy
in this group has always been where your
sneakers wear your sneakers
i don't know how i'm going to pull off a
pair of dior sneakers with my ninja
turtles shirt
right now for an on camera thing i'm
wearing a santa claus hawaiian shirt
like
we know my my fashion so like i can't be
you can't go like 90s 80s pop culture
outfit and then boom
eighteen thousand dollar diora's on the
feed it's just why not
why not it's fashionable i would
actually expect you to wear that
and somebody on the outside would be
like oh i know he got money because to
pull all that off and then wear it to
yours
i know he's probably an exec somewhere
no he's either an exec or some youtube
vlogger that i'm not keeping up with
that's like tick-tock stars are getting
paid out this [ __ ]
jeff cj like we're sneaker heads so what
if the dior is our first
pair like you're one's the first way it
only fits right it only makes sense man
true it's a good way to start for sure i
mean yeah well
why not right but i mean i just you know
it's i'm not saying that i'm
i'm against wearing those brands or
having them it's just i've never
really owned anything like that before
so for me but do believe i cop those
your weddings your uh
i'm wearing them everywhere all the
major occasions you're going to see me
freshen them to yours
see no that's what's the the right thing
is like if you have a pair and you know
how to split it up into a bunch of
pieces of content you're really getting
your investment you know
exactly i'm going to sneaker cleaners
i'm doing youtube pranks with them
i'm doing you know again i hate to i'm
not a vlogger maybe secretly i want to
be but like if you know how to split
this up into sneaker content
for br kicks then maybe these are worth
it instead of getting that rent paid
so can we talk quickly about my guy
with the video going around he's eating
cereal
cocoa puffs outside of dior we're
talking about people with disposable
income i know that these shoes are
retailing for two thousand dollars
but why are we disrespecting the sneaker
game by
putting cereal in our shoes like wait
he's eating all the diors like that
he's putting the cereal in the shoe
pouring milk on top of it
spoon in the in the in the where your
foot go
scooping out see that's like a whole
[ __ ] you to like
oh that's
that lost the raffle who wear their
kicks and who's really about the culture
like that's the type of stuff that i'm
talking about
these are the people who get or that
have
50 000 stacks of of a release of jordan
ones and pick a color
and people who really want them can't
get it you know what i mean that's why
i'm kind of like yo at this point
should i keep him so that another hype
piece don't get him
now you now christian from a philosopher
philosophical perspective
i'm kind of like maybe i need to protect
the culture and keep them and and
i feel like some [ __ ] protect it from
bad guys like
don't we don't reach our precious cargo
sneakers
[Laughter]
it's so wild that we are in situations
where you enter a raffle and i know they
said don't call it a raffle
but if you win you can pay two thousand
dollars
for a pair of sneakers oh thank you for
that privilege
that i am now afforded the opportunity
to spend two thousand dollars
on a pair of jordan washington that
we've seen
white and gray white and stone colorways
and it really is
just that like okay again peek into the
future guys
see how far that louis vuitton remember
when the louis vuitton
whether they were bootleg or not when
vaton uh
started doing the swooshes on a pair of
white on white air forces
like i i'm scared of what the dior print
is going to start looking like on
all these other sneakers that then
devalue the diors you know
that's true
yeah also low-key talk about the most
like nerve-wracking walk back home
like yours
everybody see that you got to take the
uber you got to call the uber as soon as
you get out the store
yeah point to point door-to-door i'm not
hell no
daughter doing my diors i sound like pop
smoke right now
this is why i'm excited for the nba to
come back because i heard pj tucker he
brought 60 pairs
and i would put money down that one of
those 60 pairs has to be the dr ones
in the western conference finals i'm not
i'm not predicting this but like i mean
pj pulls him out
to ballin yeah he's holding once before
he has i believe he has think about this
before when i first saw them like when
they
i first saw the link that it dropped
like at first i was like i again type
[ __ ] right
but then i was thinking like yo i really
need to like look for like the size 14
15s
that they have there just like a copy
and then resell to a ball player
that's yeah i mean that's good thinking
that's
the right thinking christian like you're
like oh should i get my size no
get it for the players who have the
money to buy them
right right we're gonna do the type of
delivery we're like hey here's my
address come by
and it's gonna be a whole like exchange
you know you gotta pull up you gotta
pull up like outside of msg like yeah i
know you didn't get those do's
what's yours i got your size i got you
that's the team name for me name
five players to me that you guys think
would rock the uh d or jordan ones
on court yeah number one pj of course
j.r smith jr of course um
devin booker maybe no not devin he's
wearing kobe's
um mantras will wear them oh yeah all
right
just wear them these look these are
current right current you guys are on
teams right now
i think he's agnostic he'll he'll wear
whatever he wants right
right yeah right or is he reebok well he
ah he is reebok that is true but i think
i see more kobe's this year so maybe
yeah i would say i mean i would have
said uh
shy or shay but he doesn't he could
still do it
he could still do it huh
yeah it's still family like you know
kobe was wearing jordans
you know me like you could you could do
it but i i don't think i think out the
gate they would want them to wear
you know what i'm saying like you know
conversely let it cool off
let it heat up a little bit shay let it
heat up here's another thing because i
would have said
coos but he just got signed so now i'm
like are all these guys
are yeah speaker choices like i would
have even said
uber but like these guys have made wild
like
distinct uh choices in their footwear
that they're all signed now
like that's how they're making waves i
feel like my dark horse is luca
i feel like if he came out and he walked
up he rocked yours if the world would
implode
well so yeah jordan brand athletes we he
luca zion
hate him would he rotate him right what
do you rock him on court maybe it's a
shoot around type deal
yeah if they're down in the series he
would i feel like
someone's gotta talk about me he's got
that mamba mentality if he's not winning
he's gonna win in some other category
right so the the story behind the dior's
was
the dior family your company made 13 000
pairs right
5 000 were for top viewer clients
the rest of the 8 000 that was left over
was for the rest of the world
what if they made more than that 13k
you know what if they did 130 000. what
does that look like for dior what's it
look like for me
make my would i have a pair i don't know
i don't know what the math is somebody
could do the math on the side like jeff
said
but if 5 million people try to cop them
and you have five million pairs
what's that 10 billion
10 10 10 billion with a b five billion
pairs is still selling yeah
yeah yeah anybody trying to cop them
yes of course we didn't know ahead of
time that that that
it was that exclusive we knew it was
exclusive but only
8 000 pairs available if i come in if i
come in the house and
no matter how if i told my wife oh yeah
i won this raffle
in 2k and then i still drive a nissan
cube
you know good conversation you know when
it really doesn't work when five pairs
show up
one day and you're just like yeah nike
did their
their clearance and it's just like no
it's still your money that
you don't you only have two feet right
it's true
like but i do like all those shoes i go
but yeah i got hooked up through bleach
report
they sent us a pair they just sent them
100 bucks
i got the media days yeah they get sent
to him i'm a huge laker fan
cj i want you to also think about too
like yeah you'd be rocking to be yours
in a cube but like
what about that that picture when you
step out the car
yeah your foot hits the ground bro you
know like i could be there to capture
that for you
i would love that like a slow-mo like me
coming out of my nissan cube
and then well it would only be like it
would touch the ground but i wouldn't
press my foot down
because you can't increase it you can
increase it and then i would be like cut
and then i would put them right
back in the box take a picture throw
them on stockx